hey guys it's evan caitlin podcast the
show that's like the middle of a
cinnamon roll except where that could
through the whole thing and so it's like
a giant middle parts like a giant middle
part with the crusts cut off
yeah all right so in today's podcast
we're gonna talk about the algorithm our
thoughts around the algorithm a series a
series i think one of my theories is how
you are the algorithm i think there's a
cool catchphrase because every wants the
title at you are the but it's cool right
you are okay what else are we talking
about today we're also gonna be playing
a game kind of like the newlywed game
but with better questions because we
need paper to redo their answers beer be
[Music]
you got a watch and we're back yeah so
we're gonna play a newlyweds game or
type game where we ask each other
questions and then we'll write our
answers on a piece of paper and then the
other person will see if they get it
right or not
yeah and and we'll see if we match up
the same answer yeah all right so for
the algorithm we have been analyzing it
for a long time and disclaimer here we
don't really have any insider
information we're just trying to pull
all of our observations from our videos
insights that we've gotten from other
creators and some insights that we've
gleaned by watching videos from YouTube
or you know statements put out by
YouTube but I think that we have some
theories yeah that are interesting good
theories and I want to discuss them
between the two of us and with you guys
to get your thoughts on them so make
sure to like leave your own thoughts
down in the comments below - yeah or do
you want to start with this okay like it
was like juicy like I don't know I feel
like we're talking about conspiracy
theories but it's like realistic yeah
realistic honest art that you are the
algorithm theory and I'm gonna have to
explain that Kalyan doesn't happen but I
think it's great all right so so we have
this theory that the audience is our
like teachers that are grading videos
every video that they watch each video
that they pass by each video that they
will only watch a little bit and exit
out of that's a data point that YouTube
is taking in and it's collecting all
that information and it's also
collecting theoretically information
about what type of videos you watch what
type of person you might be and then
what is doing is it's matching
similar profiles to you and what they
watch like so if you're a very similar
type of person as person B then they
might show you some of the videos that
person B watches because you're so
similar and same goes other way if you
really like this one channel
and then you watch every single video
and person B who's very similar to you
doesn't watch that channel yet it might
recommend that channel to them you
haven't talked about the grading oh yeah
and it's kind of like so if you watch a
video all the way through that's like
maybe a B or something if you watch all
their through I think it's you get an A
I think it's easy to describe it and
like as like a point system point system
okay yeah if you if you are shown a
video and you pass by it that's like
negative 20 points if you're shown a
video and you click on it that's like 10
points if you watch it that's 20 points
if you like it that's 30 if you comment
that's 40 you know if you share it
that's a hundred yeah whatever whatever
it is whatever point value is assigned
to each action and so in that way as you
are engaging with videos on YouTube or
deciding not to engage them or whatever
the behavior behavior is you are kind of
like scoring that video and it's taking
that data in addition to the other data
that it has and it's kind of making
recommendations based around that yeah
that's our theory yeah and I think it
kind of makes sense in a way and I think
that I mean you know one really easy
example to see it working is when we
first publish a video it goes out to our
subscribers I mean what we'll hit that
later well no no I was gonna say we
don't know that it doesn't go to other
people oh we get data on how our
subscribers reacts to it yeah but I
think in general and this is I guess
another theory that we have when you
first publish a video it goes out to
your subscribers and depending on how
your subscribers interact that video it
might push it out to a broader audience
yeah that's another theater that's
another is that one have a cool name
subscriber gate okay so we have you I'll
get it I'll grab them and subscriber
again subscriber gate yeah because it
does tell you um how its performing
specifically with your subscribers and
it also tells you how
later on it'll tell you how its
performing with non subscribers so
YouTube is dividing those two viewer
groups and our guess is they're
calculating it somewhat differently -
yeah and you know I think the
complicated thing about this whole
system is I mean I don't know too much
about machine learning but that's what
YouTube is doing I don't know too much
yeah but that's the thing it's like CPG
gray did a really interesting video on
machine learning and how like you know
when you want a machine to learn
something you create a greater robot
that grades performance of an algorithm
so you don't really know what the
algorithm is doing you've designed the
robot that tests how well that algorithm
is doing does that robot then change the
behavior of the algorithm yeah so it's
like the algorithm keeps on evolving it
tries this it tries this it tries this
and there might be multiple multiple
versions of the algorithm running at the
same time and basically the grading room
looks at each of the different like
sorting algorithms and it says ooh this
one really is not doing well you know
it's like when when this algorithm is
running and suggesting videos to people
it's doing very poorly watch time is
down kills it off so I can algorithm
that's only based on thumbnails and it's
like oh man if this person sees a face
in the thumbnail they're really gonna
click it and it shows a bunch of
thumbnails and it's like guess it didn't
like those faces yeah yeah so but it's
also it's like and you know I think
initially YouTube was saying okay watch
time is the number one important thing
it's changed and it's changed yeah so
the grading system on what is like what
like you know so the algorithm was
trying to do something and for a while I
think that the grading were algorithm
was saying okay let's increase watch
time and the algorithm did that but
there's a lot of negative consequences
it's just increasing watch time you know
an interesting thing and I wonder if
this is just algorithm learning or if
this is YouTube purposely doing
something even though it's potentially
against what the algorithm should do is
you know there is a little while with
like the rise of daily vloggers and this
matter where you were awarded you were
rewarded for a frequency and now there's
been like so much creator burnout in the
news and this and that and a lot of it's
because people feel the pressure to post
up in the algorithm so that daily
content wasn't rewarded as much and a
lot of people are upset oh is that a
theory no I think that they said that
really yeah because to me it was a
theory I didn't know that they had
confirmed I think that they confirmed it
that's interesting yeah yeah because now
it's like potentially punishing people
or maybe not punishing but you're saying
it's not it's not waiting it as much not
waiting well I don't think it was a
matter of like oh if you post a bunch
you as a whole are weighted higher
because of that I think it was just like
um it would show your you know
subscribers new things and if you post
every single day you always have a new
thing that's newer than other stuff I
don't think it was like just that it was
rewarding you for posting a lot yeah
but now let's say it's not based on new
things not that I knew it was but let's
say it's based on something else and
then some of your videos aren't making
it to your subscribers yeah yeah yeah
cuz like oh there's so much that goes
into all of this you know we see some
larger content creators who have a
bigger audience that they can poll
sometimes ask hey have you seen our my
latest video and sometimes like almost
50% of people say no which is crazy yeah
and maybe it was just too far down in
the feed or maybe you know the last
three videos that that creator put out
those people didn't watch and then to
the fourth when they put out it it's
farther down their recommendations or
whatever it is you know it's interesting
but I mean I think that when when we are
first starting out on YouTube I think I
kind of put more responsibility on
YouTube itself and they do have a lot of
responsibility but I think as we've been
in this game for longer I'm realizing
that YouTube is almost like
lose-lose in so many different ways no
matter how they change it if they like
incentivize one thing that they're gonna
be punishing another thing you know it's
like just based on the system of rewards
there's always gonna be you know because
YouTube there's infinite content
basically yeah and if you reward
something you're inherently almost
punishing the opposite you know and and
the same thing with advertisers and
content creators you know if they don't
keep the advertisers happy than a lot of
people who rely on Adsense don't get the
Adsense and if they like you know filter
things too much then they're gonna lose
based on the general awareness of them
and people's feelings towards them and
everything like that I think that
YouTube's Justin like him an envious
spot oh yeah because also know they
can't win and like they can't like spend
the money needed to respond every
comment and respond to every creator and
it stinks because like in a way they've
lowered the barrier to entry so much
which is great but that means that so
many people can create content and so
many people are and they just can't keep
up with it yeah but I think that's why
they did things like like robots yeah so
robots and algorithms that's why they
did things like they changed the like
criteria for monetizing your channel for
exams yeah cuz if you're not monetized
they don't really have to monitor you
yeah but still I mean the amount of
hours of monetized content uploaded oh
it's nice I'm just saying I'm sure much
but if you yeah but I'm sure it did help
yeah if you look at the people under
that cutoff there's potentially more
people in that group than the people
above the cutoff yes you know so I'm
sure it's still cut down a lot cut down
a lot of their work another interesting
thing going back to what you're saying
earlier with how if they change one
thing in the algorithm it's even if it
rewards one group it's gonna punish
another group also no matter what the
thing that's being awarded is as soon as
people figure out they're gonna
yes that's such a such an interesting
point it's like they also like you know
they keep the algorithm secret for a ton
of reasons I'm sure but I'm sure one of
the reasons is if the algorithm was
public people would play to that and
like win yeah well if you already try I
mean this is what we're doing right now
is like talking about it trying to
figure it out yeah okay so one thing
those interesting you know switching off
of YouTube for a while but I'll bring it
back around Instagram remember when we
first started doing Instagram and the
algorithm for Instagram was understood
and people were just like playing the
game with like the like BOTS and the
pods and everything is so easy to
explain what what pods are yeah okay so
Instagram pods are basically you can
join a group of people sometimes it's
like in a similar type like a similar
type of profile is you so like a
woodworking group or a crafting group or
something and you have times at certain
times of the day we're like so like
every hour on the hour or twice a day or
whatever you agree to post if you're
gonna post at one of the designated
times and you put in your username and
then everyone gets a message and
everyone in the pod goes and likes
everybody else's and you all post at the
same time and it's supposed to like give
you that initial boost you need to go on
the discover page we try it very briefly
and no stressful it was like horrible I
did not like it difference yeah it felt
weird like we tried it briefly and then
we stopped it briefly I know it works
like there are people so many people
yeah and I'm like we've seen the results
of it and like it is hackable in a way
and I know that Instagram really has cut
down on that a ton yeah I've been really
like going after it
they've been going to the point where
it's like in some ways difficult like
you know a an Instagram theory that we
heard is if you don't reply to people
within an hour your reply isn't counted
as engagement which is so dumb so dumb
we mean
we reply to everyone basically I mean we
try we try our best we reply it it's
getting to be a lot
yeah it's getting to feel that we reply
whether or not it's within an hour or
after an hour we're not gonna like
ignore people just cuz it's like oh it's
been after an hour but unless it gets
lost that's not annoying people just
cause like instagrams notification
system is getting a decent amount of
likes and it only shows so many
notification items in your notification
screen the comments just get buried even
look at the like like the heart tab or
whatever you could go to the most recent
thing and sort by new and then call I go
there cuz it defaults to top and I don't
know how to turn it off oh yeah but
anyways oh yeah but I guess like what
one reason why I brought up Instagram is
because it's much easier to game
Instagram in a way because the content
that does well on Instagram is a little
bit easier to do than YouTube you know
you can do like a quote thing or you can
like take stuff from another place or
you know you could just do pretty
pictures of whatever and that can do
well if you play the game right kaylynn
trying to get okay we've got a little
kitty guest our second guest on the
podcast is a return guest yep
but with Instagram you know you can kind
of game the system easier and win you
don't even need to be like making your
own content you can like you know gather
content from other places or whatever
and there's so many like Instagram
accounts that are doing that I'm sure
it's companies behind them but they just
repost everybody's stuff and when you go
to the discover page most of what's on
the discovery page is repost errs yeah
so I think that Instagram they really
needed to crack down on it because it is
easier to like make content that you can
game the system with but with YouTube
it's really hard to make content to game
the system with because no matter what
with YouTube if you don't have good
content you you just I don't
or like original I mean you can't just
like I mean sure people do but you can't
just like literally repost you can't
literally repos you can't do commentary
type stuff and there are certain genres
that are easier to make content and
perhaps I'm not sure but with youtuber
it's it's a little bit hard harder in a
way to game the system because you have
you first have to have good content but
even when you have good content that
doesn't mean that you're gonna be
successful you still need to you know
reach the audience that you need to
reach and you need visibility and all of
that other stuff another theory that I
have is you know how I mean we've gotten
a decent mount of people saying this
like Oh weird I thought I was subscribed
to you guys I'm not I'm subscribe ugh
that's not like people have been talking
about that for the past like it's not a
new thing necessarily but yeah the
unsubscribe but bug and YouTube denies
it yeah you YouTube denies it yeah we'll
get people saying like weird I thought
it was on I was subscribed to you guys
it's up now where we've had people
saying like I know I would subscribe to
you guys and now I'm unsubscribe that's
weird and so I have a theory about why
it happens Mandela effect so my theory
is that YouTube you know they'll go
through rounds of like unsubscribing
BOTS yes and there's sometimes where so
so when we receive comments some are
automatically published some are held
for review if they have certain like
flagged words in them and then some are
marked as potential spam by YouTube yeah
and sometimes it makes sense it's like
someone linking somewhere outside of
YouTube will get marked as spam someone
that you know just says like love your
video check out my channel like there's
certain kind of generic things that will
get flagged as spam but sometimes a
comment will get flagged and I'm like I
have no idea why this is like the spam
like this person's commented on our
stuff before like we were totally normal
comment that's weird and I'll prove it
and whatever but there was apparently
something about those commenters that
made youtube think that they were BOTS
or spammy or whatever and so I think you
know there's some sort of behavior
behavior that humans are
doing that is making YouTube think
they're robots and I think those are the
people that are getting unsubbed maybe
that's interesting they go through like
bot purges where they're like perfect
guys
but I'm sure there's like bot deletions
here and there too yeah I don't know I
don't know I'd be curious to see if
someone who has experienced being like
getting unsubbed from a creator has
gotten ups unsub from multiple creators
oh yeah like all the ones I know right
not necessarily I mean you might notice
a couple o like so like like some
viewers they've never been out to
unsubscribe from someone but if you have
an unsubscribe maybe it's a common thing
for that account to get unsubscribe yeah
like like if we went to someone's
channel who we were subscribed to and we
were unsubscribed from them and then we
notice it happened a couple more times
maybe that means like we were at a
higher likelihood for being flagged I
don't know I don't know I don't know
that's weird
another thing that I want to talk about
during this like algorithm talk is also
I know it's like a very touchy subject
but the monetization and performance and
the algorithm that ranks your videos and
I think that one thing that people are
commonly upset by is YouTube says okay
the the performance of your video has
nothing to do with its monetization
status right but what links both of them
down here is like the decision matrix
that watching
Evans doing a very elaborate um Sharpie
diagram okay okay so let's just say like
you have two circles you have your
performance and you have your
monetization status yes but they're
completely separate that's what YouTube
is saying they're completely separate
this doesn't affect this but below below
them in like the process chart there's
some computer-based judgment call that's
made that says okay we're gonna
demonetized this and we're gonna you
know limit is performance because it's
like rated you know for it has like
adult content editor
whatever so technically monetization
status and performance don't have
anything to do with each other because
they're they're both decisions spent out
by this this is decision maker but
things are affecting that decision maker
that yes could have an effect on both so
technically YouTube is saying the truth
when they say monetization doesn't
affect performance
but monetization status is a symptom of
what your hidden scores are in terms of
reporting
that's like saying saying okay the fact
that you have a stomachache and you
didn't run that race very well they're
not related at all but both of them are
linked to the fact that you ate pizza it
sounds like the determining thing yeah
yeah because you ate pizza you have a
stomachache in you and run very well
yeah it's kinda like that you know yeah
and I'm not sure if that's true or not
that's just a theory that I have and I
have no evidence I mean like plays a
Shane Dawson music in the background it
is interesting to talk about that and
this is the kind of stuff that like we
get around other youtubers we talk dirty
we all want to talk about it you know
cuz you can't talk about the stuff with
people in your everyday life but I don't
know I think it's interesting to like
Bri is I think another thing that we've
been thinking of recently because of
kind of how we've been growing as a
channel and you know finding new video
content types that we really enjoy is
how kind of some of the theory I talked
about earlier where when you first
publish the video we believe that the
your subscribers reactions to your video
how they grade it in a way by their
behavior or lack of behavior determine
this what YouTube thinks about your
video because like YouTube doesn't have
the time or resources or anything to
grade your video themselves because it's
a hard complex things hard complex
things so they rely on your viewers to
grade your video for them and then based
on that grade they'll show it to
you know an audience or whatever yeah
and I think that one consequence of that
is it's really hard to change your
content type yeah I mean that's
something we hear you know all the other
podcasts talk about how they feel kind
of trapped trapped but I think that like
what's the bigger issue is when you have
let's say you have a hundred thousand
subscribers because that's a round
number and you want to grow that number
bigger and you make the content that
your audience likes then they grade it
well and they might push it out to a
broader audience but mainly the audience
that is similar to them does that make
sense kind of based on our like you are
the algorithm mixed with subscriber gate
you know because you know your
subscriber gate that are like the
gatekeepers to the broader YouTube
audience but if your gatekeepers is a
niche audience in a way then they'll
open up the gates to people interested
in that niche yeah so it's like in a way
the subscriber gate opens the gates to
exactly the people that they are right
so it's like if you are an each
community it's it's maybe hard broaden
out unless that nice community is
something that's widely applicable
somehow pass a certain point I don't
know yeah I mean if that in each
community is like you play for at night
what about this specific game that's a
nice so what about what is your niche
content but your comedy then that comedy
almost Trump's the niche content for the
broader audience like let's say that you
stitch well let's see you crochet you
know let's say you're a crochet channel
and you go go really big in like your
crochet community but in every video
you're crocheting something hilarious
and like the whole video is comedic then
when you when you when your subscriber
gate releases you to the broader
audience then the broader audience
washes you and they're like whoa this is
hilarious and then they'll grow and will
spread and spread and spread and spread
because like it's
it's like the comedy aspect of it is
enough to appeal to a huge broad
audience but only if you built your
audience based on a comedy aspect if you
started out just doing crocheting
tutorials and you build your audience
and they're people who like to crochet
and just want to toriel's and then you
start cracking jokes and being funny
then a lot of those people may not
respond well but if from the beginning
you're a hilarious crochet Channel yeah
but most people change
change to some degree you know everyone
has like a bigger smaller degree of
change yeah but but when I was saying
people feel trapped I think that's why
because you know when they try to do
something that's maybe a little bit out
of their norm it's not gonna perform as
well
and it just stops it often just like
your performance like with some of our
videos we release them and they grow and
they grow and they grow but sometimes we
release them they get whatever views
they get and then you stop there to stop
yeah but but it's not just that it's
that they're even there initial
performance yeah initial performance is
low and then they just stop them yeah so
that's what I'm saying it's like if
you're trying to you know if you're a
woodworker and you're like you know what
I'm gonna try welding because I really
want to learn how to weld mm-hmm
so if you're a woodworking channel and
you're like you know I really want to
try welding I'm gonna try welding but
all your audience they're woodworkers
and they're watching your video for
woodworking tutorials and you do welding
they're like I'm not gonna watch this
because I don't have a welder but I
think that there's a high likelihood of
people who like both watching in that
community in a way but I'm I'm saying
the specific situation where you are
only doing woodworking only doing weird
working but like but also it's like if
you're making the type of content that
appeals to woodworkers and welders
somehow then you might be able to branch
out kind of like okay let's bring out
that crochet channel again let's say
that like people who like crochet also
like comedy you know and half
your audience that watches your crochet
videos also watch comedy videos that
might be a way to like branch out that's
not the best example like a lot that
people who crocheted don't like comedy
but when I think of like comedy based
channels I don't think crochet tutorials
like may not have found jenna Marbles if
I didn't make her watch dinner yeah no
she likes jenna Marbles yeah but you
know what I mean yeah um I think like
the woodworking and metalworking but
still I mean we've heard even with that
specific example people who have
struggled bringing in a new type of
making into their channel when it was
previously one style of making yeah you
know yeah I think specifically it is to
give it an example that we feel you know
comfortable giving because we're like in
it for us you know we grew up in the DIY
and maker community at kind of our
channel and as we've kept on making
videos we we just find making a certain
type of video to be really fun kind of
some of our more recent content we've
just been having so much fun making it
and and academe just happy and yeah yeah
the reason I the videos are more its to
categorize it like the division between
the stuff that wasn't as fun to make and
edit and the stuff that is more fun to
make and edit is kind of about our style
of presenting it yeah it's less nowadays
it's less scripted and it's less about
the steps and it's more about the
experience more about just like hanging
out with us while we make stuff and like
we still talk about what we're doing and
there might be like tips or something if
we're like oh shoot this works really
well you know or whatever but it's not
like a formal tutorial whereas we used
to be a lot more step-by-step well I
think another part of it is you know
we've gotten it's hard to put this into
words but when you are teaching
something both of us are you know both
of us like to be perfectionist in our
ideal state especially Caitlyn like if
I'm supposed to be teaching
something I'd like to know it yeah you
know and and that would really limit us
yeah a very limited number of videos
yeah exactly we just finished recording
a welding video which is what I was
think about welding girls yeah and it
was our first one doing it by ourselves
and we're totally not professionals and
we hit a lot of snags that I'm sure
there's a lot of people out there who
have you know tried their hand at
welding you know I'm sure they can
relate to it but I wouldn't have felt
comfortable being a teacher of welding
in that circumstance so we just would
have not recorded the video and it also
opens yourself up to I don't know I'm
not sure about the best way to describe
them are but like people who want to
correct you and like you know there are
there are a ton of people who leave
really great great comments and really
helpful advice and really great feedback
but you know once you leave that the
nicer maker community and you get to
kind of some broader audience that don't
know you and don't understand what
you're trying to do where you're trying
to learn and show your process and stuff
you you open yourself up to a whole slew
of different types of comments you know
I actually think that's like not only
outside of the maker community there's a
lot of people in the maker community
that you know you want to tell you how
to do it there that's not really
something we get a ton of on our channel
anymore yeah yeah yeah it's so true like
as we've shifted from like follow along
with us along this journey and hopefully
we'll share some of the lessons we've
learned along the way when we move to
that instead of saying step one do this
step two do this step three do this and
you know that best honestly that was
stressful to put out that type of
content cuz also you know you don't want
to do something wrong when we did once
and we took down that video yeah cuz it
was something kind of dangerous those
two something kind of dangerous and that
that haunted us for a little bit
we took it down so we took it down the
only video we've ever taken down and we
don't want to be in that situation as
much now it's like if we happen to do
something unsafe like sometimes we'll
like forget
on a respirator yes something you know
we're like oh we're just gonna like sand
the corner off of this resin it's it's
still and we should wear it so and I we
appreciate the comment saying I hate hey
you should do that yeah but it's all I
said but we're not doing it from a place
of authority and teaching exactly less
people doing things because if you're
saying like here's all the things you
need to do if you're doing a resin
project and then you don't wear a
respirator then someone could watch that
and think oh I don't need to wear a
respirator but if we're like hey we just
started playing with resin and we're
gonna try ten experiments you know and
give you like tips we've learned are you
okay you struggling with that jacket
[Music]
anyways I guess it's just like if people
know you're not coming from a place of
expertise they'll seek out that
expertise elsewhere on YouTube and then
there's less pressure on you to do
everything perfect you know oh yes yes
now you can see the supervisor she's
been here Doh hole all the time I've
been just um tilted the camera down
after struggling with a jacket forever
got some air time this is the reward for
people who watch the video you get to
barely see our cat because she's black
and she blends in with my chair
sometimes you can see her eyes when she
opens them for a moment well I think too
that that might be a pretty good place
to wrap up our algorithm talk yeah we
kind of we kind of strayed there at the
end of it I think it was a good place to
wrap it up shoot their game yeah let's
play our game game time
[Music]
okay yeah I got something in my eye then
I was looking for my phone might've
looked like I was having a seizure but
it wasn't we both have questions for
each other yeah so some questions are
questions that we're both going to
answer and some questions are questions
that we're gonna ask the other person
about ourselves okay first question who
is more competitive because you can tell
if we're just writing names so you can
tell like how many letters are in it so
when you're thinking about me being
competitive are you thinking like like
when we play video games are you
thinking like when we have discussions
about things life just oh haha I love it
I love it think about it I think I'm
just very easygoing I just let things
slide and everything like that but like
Kaitlyn like wants to like get to
enhancer or something like that or I
want to express my opinion every now and
then in video games I might get
competitive but it's only if I'm good at
that video game yeah I feel like that is
like the one exception if you're if
you're good at a video game you will get
kind of competitive yeah and if I'm not
good I won't be too competitive cuz like
I know I got no chances you're saying
okay if you could wear one clothing item
from the other person
sizing logistics aside it just magically
be in your size what would it be
we both write down our answers and we
both guess the other person's answer I
thought that that's what I understood I
thought we were both like doing those
types of questions like where we have
different answers okay
maybe I have lots of nice clothing items
why is it taking you so long
want me to go first you guess what I
wrote I'm actually just curious as I
figured but I have no idea um my super
fuzzy socks nope
I put robe you have a robe you have the
same row but you have like a lighter
robe okay for an article of clothing of
mine that you would like to wear
sweatpants no I have sweat pants I'm
wearing them now what was it
cashmere sweater oh you already wear
that yeah but what is my favorite tool
callipers that would have been a good
answer Leatherman Micra oh man we don't
even know each other
come on like you're seeing recently I
know I know
stay there you do love the counter more
than you use the Leatherman I would
argue ask you one that's just about me
since that was nice about you hmm
okay you might know this what did I want
to be when I grew up right there like
the first thing I want it to be it's
more of a situation down I want to see
if I get it exactly okay for your job
when you grew up you wanted to be a cat
lady living with your mom I was like and
then the next one after that was I
wanted to work at a vet that was only
for cats
yeah No
get out of here dogs kappa oh my god
cats only oh my cats what was when you
were younger I know you wanted to be an
inventor yes I wanted to be an inventor
did you have an engineer no I was just
always inventor and engineer maker in
general so this has been like my path
man I have swerved a lot more than you I
mean in the end I live with you and I
have one cat which is also good
yes very good except she doesn't know us
left since we've got a little loud all
right who has worse handwriting oh man
this is close
funny it's like I always thought that I
had like really bad chicken scratch
anybody and I like chicken scratch and
because I could draw people are always
like Oh Kaitlin can you can you write
this card for my sister and like do cool
letters and I'm like you can like Drake
draw pretty letters for you it's drawing
right yeah you draw a font you don't
that's not your natural hand you see
your natural handwriting right next to
like like words that she wrote in a way
that she meant to be pretty I can make
it legible do you literally can't I
can't if I write like a three-year-old
super slowly in a doctor yeah okay if we
weren't doing YouTube stuff or our
previous jobs that we actually had what
would you want to do for work I'm going
to guess that you want would be an
electronics product designer know what
inventor entrepreneur
what you were you you're an entrepreneur
right now I'll just do it in a slightly
different people okay what okay what do
you think that I I was pretty close
though like product design that's kind
of close to inventor webcomics
totally I started a webcomic named
college I started it like three
different times with three different art
styles and then I didn't write anything
past the first chapter and I didn't know
where to go with it I never posted it
online but I think that would be so cool
that would be so cool really good I mean
back when I wanted to do that people
weren't like I knew like one webcomic
artists that I think was doing it
full-time well you know that was before
patreon and stuff well maybe one day
when we're retiring we can keep on doing
this part-time you can draw your comics
part-time I mean I would rather be doing
what we're doing than comics I just
think it would have been a cool
alternate path eleven goal yeah all
right so who carries this channel who
carries this channel I mean we both have
really crucial roles with without me you
would have a hard time making videos but
you could make quality videos without
you I wouldn't be able to make quality
videos no way I wouldn't have like the
motivation to do it to the quality that
I'd like and then I wouldn't be happy
with it so I probably wouldn't do it
I just takes like a lot of like focused
dedication so much of it is in the
editing which you carry all of the load
and like the story and the flow and
everything my flow would be this all
over the place I could maybe make a
certain type of youtube video but like I
just I just don't think I would how do
you think um like how would you would
yours be less story based and more just
like fast forwarding to stuff - be
fast-forwarding through self
or I God like take videos of the project
as I did it and then at the end I'll
show what I made and I'd walk you
through how I did it
thank mark Rober like mark Roberson why
not maybe but the story wouldn't be
nearly as good tomorrow for the editing
wouldn't be as good I think like I if it
was just me the channel content would be
slightly different
yeah because you know there's a lot of
stuff that I might be too intimidated to
start on my own and I think I probably
would have leaned more into my expertise
which is slightly more on the like
beginner DIY side yeah you know cuz I
did DIY stuff but it would probably be
kind of like limited tool type things
also because like I wouldn't want to
accumulate a bunch of tools I don't like
having a lot of things let's try this
yeah I'm like starts all this crap and
then Caitlin's alone that finishes it
nicely and Caitlin turns it into
something nice videos you would probably
be doing the same type of projects but
the editing would be totally different I
would be doing similar editing but it'd
probably be a mix of like DIY slash
craftier stuff and like my boyfriend
does my makeup what's my favorite
material that we've worked with resin I
think you might guess like welding like
no it's resin this resin resin is great
we're gonna do more we have more resin
projects in the works we do they're
they're planned yeah they're planned
yeah we just need to get to need to get
to them okay next question
what's the thing were most likely to go
viral for like an existing video
oh no no like like like what's like like
something that we're gonna do in the
future that we're gonna go viral for so
like a paper thing would have to be
YouTube videos it's just like it's what
in life are we gonna go viral
I can't like say one of the ones that we
actually have planned
don't say anything we actually have so
this is like an imagined imaginary this
is something we've talked about
theoretically but we don't actually have
it land okay so I think that we might
follow Jimmy dressed by going viral with
a weapon No yeah okay wait no I was
supposed to guess
oh no no we both will supposed to hold
our things up and see if they're
different Oh
that only works when it's like the only
answers are Evan or Caitlin okay all
right so something cat related no what's
that what's the answer a barn - Workshop
conversion ooh yeah which we've talked
about because like we eventually will
need a larger workshop than we thought
like if we move like a little bit
farther from the city and we get some
land and maybe there's an existing barn
on and then maybe that barn is
structurally sound enough to turn into a
workshop it'd be really cool
it'd be really cool all right next
question okay okay ready the next one's
like a challenge one this is a question
for you to answer about me ah it's kind
of related to one of the videos that I
said I would do if I just left my own
devices mm-hmm list the makeup items I
use to get ready for filming okay and
this is like not on the lazy days all
right
so okay first off you do your fancy
sunscreen oh yeah that's bonus points I
didn't I didn't write that down all
right now over that you do sometimes
like spot touch-ups with a thing yeah
not really anymore okay that was a long
time ago when I was having like then you
do like a like blush that is an item
it's not the order but you don't have to
get the order right but you also do a
powder yeah I do it a baby powder okay
so you did a clear how to base I already
mentioned the blush yeah and
you do eye shadow that is another item
which always confused me people because
your shadow is beneath your eye but
shadow above but like if you think about
a shadow the Sun is usually above you
a shadow should be called a brow shadow
brow shadow that's what there should be
called people let's start a change.org
petition so this brow shadow so it makes
sense
let's invent it make a youtube video on
it and then that'll be what goes viral
just a shadow okay and then you do
eyeliner mm-hmm
and you do mascara mm-hmm that's it
right you're looking at me by there's
still more so I'll keep on going you do
the torture device in your eyes yeah
there are three more and they're all
advanced oh I would say advanced isn't
not like they're hard I know this form
of jeez I don't even know you
okay I know you steel in your makeup
with the spray no I was gonna get really
sweaty well I did gave given up now what
part of your face does it go on there
are two other things that are related to
blush I'm not wearing them now now right
now I'm only wearing blush and one of
the things that you forgot oh oh eyebrow
pencil yeah Brown it's not pencil but
yeah three more when lips know oh my
makeup I just put we're like chapstick
one of them I'll scratch off these guess
- they're both related to my cheeks and
they're not blush +2 and +3 powder - and
powder these are both powders you put on
your face okay contour highlight like
it's just like the same face powder but
different colors yes
so I pretty much got it
you pretty much got you did pretty good
yeah give herself an a it's a lot of as
I was writing this I was like I consider
myself someone that doesn't wear a ton
of makeup but it's like a lot of
separate items I just don't wear
foundation so don't feel like I really
because there's like nothing on the base
I just like the clear powder is only
because I wear sunscreen in otherwise
everything melts off so I have to do
like a clear powder yeah and then all
the other things are basically so like I
should my face shows because of that you
know you know you're keeping your skin
young pretty good pretty good
it's like I could do your makeup my
boyfriend what would I want to do if we
won the lottery the same thing but with
less time pressure big house big
workshop more videos bigger bigger place
yeah yeah like afford a bigger place
yeah that's right
basically yeah I just like without the
time pressure because the pressure is
cause like we need to make it are you
we've known each other for like how many
years like 13 years 12 years coming up
on 5 years of marriage and we've known
each other since we're 18 okay my
feeling of the week is something that we
use in probably half of our videos at
least at least and it's the the Rockler
silicone project map this isn't
sponsored by them but we just always
keep our work table covered with it they
recently came out with an Excel version
which is really cool so good they
interlock so your entire workbench can
be made we do woodworking on it when we
are finishing our pieces we do resin on
it we do like every this it's great it's
just an essential for your workshop
it's very versatile okay nice you're
thinking man's also like a not sponsored
by tool from a brand well not really I
guess it's a tool as our Lincoln welder
got to play with yeah and like we're
still learning it but welding is so fun
it's so fun and the footage you get
after it beautiful yeah okay so the next
video we release after you guys listen
to this
is going to be a welding video so
spoiled that spreads because I mentioned
it earlier on this podcast well but only
the podcast people know yeah but uh yeah
that's good that's a good thing that's
definitely it's so fun
what's also like and like we've leveled
up our skill like after welding like an
entire project I feel like way more
confidence between like you know if
you're driving somewhere and somebody is
telling you all the directions and
you're like oh I got there it was like
that except now that we've figured out
how to get there by ourselves I feel
like we know it a lot better than we
done when someone was telling this
direction yeah yeah thank you guys so
much for listening to our podcast this
week thank you guys for all of the
ratings the shares the subscribe is all
of the engagement that you do remember
you are that algorithm you guys grow and
succeed and do more and and do bigger
things so we're really excited to keep
on doing what we're doing and just keep
on growing with you guys also if you
guys have stuff that you want us to talk
about we recently started a community
post thread on the podcast YouTube
channel so you can let us know there or
you gonna let us know on the video yeah
this episode or any episode but you know
we'll see it most if it's the episode or
the community post you know yeah but I
think the community post is great cuz
it's a central place where people can
put ideas and vote on what ideas they
want then so they share people people
are like what's the community town we
see everything yeah
but yeah just let us know if you guys
have specific topics or anything like
that you want to get a little see you
later poop in the poop then you do the
boopity boop what if they're pool well
that can you describe what that would be
Oh boobs their poop okay no I can't
thinks like like a head I don't think
that's like head but in their poop I
think it would be like but not on the
nose on the poop
what's this podcast about again